how's it going bad but it's very much
welcome back to problem maybe one of the
last episode I know I'm funny Jamie I
know I'm fighting Jimmy it's really
vital oh yeah oh yeah got something
shout out Pete shut up
basking in adulation I mean running the
school fairly dudes so fairly Jimmy
please what do you want payday yeah no
Pete I gave you the finger you know what
Jimmy yes
forget to scrub the school the whole
town should know about you yes you're
like the mayor I'm like the president
mark yeah dump on the doorstep
no you homunculus not a dump I said
something much I should paint a dump and
then leave it on the door send a warning
yes yeah that's a good idea
hey I'll show everyone right that's
right JJ Mike you girls wait here this
is gonna be something they'll never
forget wait Jimmy don't forget about
Gary yeah what am i Gary haven't seen
him in so long like he's supposed to be
the main villain I guess he's supposed
to be like plop it up uh somewhere I
mean Gary's got to be pretty jealous and
I took over the school when it was
originally his plan to take over the
school and now accounting got pull of
power and then we just got to go to a
tower I ride on this skateboard I don't
even know why I'm talking still and we
could just make a cut here but I'm not
gonna make a cut here let's do this
video completely without cuts because I
know somebody better be like uh pears
you got a record so far I'll sing the
Stefano Anthon and weird LIBOR answer
all right what Clanton why would we
climb on top exactly I don't want to do
that all right
ah [ __ ] you can't rush climbing for
whatever [ __ ] reason but that's okay
we can look at Jimmy's the nature gym is
Nate would I don't even know what I'm
talking about
I really don't know what we're doing up
here they never told us to plan so yeah
I'm gonna make a shake man yeah we'll go
on top of the building
and then I don't I don't have any other
plans beside that but let's just do it
all right jesus [ __ ] christ is high
get up there
I missed a rubber bed oh I gotta go feed
the up here that's it all right this
better be nice
what's it say what the [ __ ] is that
saying Paula where this mine or some
[ __ ] like that prolly yeah Bulworth
spraying that with pink clearly makes a
rash statement everyone knows that fully
worthless haha you're so funny now come
on it's not the first time the cops are
after me they're not even moving it's
like you tagged city hall well no [ __ ]
let's jump on down from City Hall that
will make a bigger statement oh you
can't [ __ ] boy yeah
to rile him up are you can't you can't
even jump from you can't even kill
yourself oh come on come on come the
[ __ ] on are you [ __ ] serious is the
point what I cut in videos because I do
stupid [ __ ] what have we got to do we
got to go in here stop hating my Diddy
that's great listen we've got a problem
I'm gonna tell me I'm the king no motor
problems I've only been gone a couple
hours what could have happened okay
thanks you remember that bread my Mac
made about restoring law and order and
improving the school no st. exactly
coming true well if anyway that's a
fight I'm right here I think Gary must
be behind it but trust me
everyone wants a fight Larry they gotta
go I'll talk to you later
oh man oh man like I have panty somebody
was high
why did it oh [ __ ] everyone hates me now
oh [ __ ]
Gary Gary Oh town county respect who the
[ __ ] is Tony okay
good enough I'll bike your waiter for me
I love you I don't even know I don't
know hey Russell
I'll come rats are chilling time lovely
I love chatting not cheating but
cheating no I never talk about it should
you want to you know well I rescue you
from the a celeb I maybe get ladies
unfair you promised shut up who loves ya
God what kind of world do we live in
where one where alcohol is minor
indiscretion right we're taking bribes
from his pupils he died one crimes he
sells advanced copies of tests the sons
of his rich friends huh wait what really
should say worried about it
Darby Harrington for one no I'm gonna
get him selling tests what if I got
evidence of him doing this that I'd
never need to drink again all right let
me see what I can do
all right we're gonna get that [ __ ] and
we're gonna get him good do you hear
that did you hear that did you hear that
say I say I say I'd [ __ ] hit
Ayrshire
hedaan sad god dammit I get punished
because he didn't say it
where the [ __ ] do we have to go all
right oh I am Tomatoes see say saying
well combined I'm going in here oh [ __ ]
this is not corrector much what are you
guys gonna do what are you guys gonna do
what are you guys gonna do what are you
guys gonna do
better desk that I couldn't seen before
ha idiots can't climb ladders all right
now we're gonna [ __ ] with them this is
what you get you [ __ ] ha [ __ ] all
right what do we got
you have my cash oh I'll pay you drive a
hard bargain quickly take a photo of us
they do the criminal thing got it get
more evidence go to school Jim why why I
asked and never answers I wonder if I
could jump down from here without dying
I could wonderful it was lovely
gentlemen but heads must have to gleam
right now la da da la da da da
now all the jocks want to beat me up too
probably
alright what you got what you got what
you got what you got what you got
shut up or I should actually kiss up all
right I'm much more beautiful now I just
need help
I can go here
huh okay shows up I need to get my grade
up don't worry he'll be here soon I'm
sure
greetings that my girlfriend she's
cheating on me yeah do you work the
tests all right another time for the
camera there we go Nick couldn't they be
less obvious about it what's up now I
get on the roof I don't have a lot of
health and why not allowed to have very
little what is it tell me follow the
prep all right oh no no way
no way that guy looks like he had taken
a [ __ ] in his pants
returned the photos all right now I just
got to return them all right got to
return the photos without getting beaten
up look at my health
one guy touching my nipple and I'm dead
dead as can be what are they going
anyway
all right so pH your pills read the disc
West when it finally appeared again and
future Puetz is planning on showing off
finishing this one so annoying like when
you finish in tyre quest and then you
die for like the most stupid reason
friends XD ah yeah this is the last
quest uh so that's pretty cool
wonder what's gonna happen yeah think of
the chilling dr. crab Oh
novelty is the most important lesson we
can teach the youth is that so then you
perfect timing test answers to rich kids
fire yet you get good playoff didn't lay
off good job Oh what's going on in the
background who said that his belly
ma all right I saved his ass he should
at least thank me
all right there's a quest here I don't
know if it's the same one
Jim is burning I guess I got to do
another one because I failed on that one
[ __ ] it's annoying fail what come here
boy hey what's up mr. Bert what's up
what's up Mike Tim is up in flames look
damn how'd that happen
there's a few down you're a degenerate
the thing I trusted you we didn't do a
single question why no saint but I tried
to bring order to the school to stop the
bullying Oh bullying I don't care about
bullying good teacher right there
you great teaching liber [ __ ] man yeah
oh yeah you had to ruin it forever you
hadn't even apply for the [ __ ] team
my life what are you talking about I
never wanted to be yeah we kids and
you've got the personality of a
jockstrap yeah well I call the police
you'll be killed for this my boy wasn't
why done for Hopkins [ __ ] stupid
people
oh did Yuri oh no there's people trapped
inside watch what we do I'm gonna give a
[ __ ] about him and kick him die he drank
my yarn he should have superpowers how
does he know he's stuck right after shut
up I'm saving this one instead how the
fire extinguisher how do I even get
inside
all right don't worry I got this kids
got this what do I have to do uh I'm no
fireman but I don't know what I'm doing
there we go that should do it
got to lift you up you're welcome
I saved your life that Gary it's a crazy
son of a [ __ ] for doing this all right
woman yes oh I got to see her panties
actually thank you ha ha ha all right
what do you want
I have apparently superpowers
ah Jay says Jason yeah
gasps yeah Seth oh yeah I forgot about
your face here we go wear this one I
guess there we go
no they're not
I just put them out you stupid [ __ ] you
are welcome oh I did not mean to do that
edit that out kids
douchebag peds is not going daddy to
that search for the what sir she just
locked me on that [ __ ] what was the
quest sasha gym for para maniac yeah
what the [ __ ] is that
what
what kind of pyromaniac lights a
building on fire
that stays inside the fire good-good guy
pyromaniac kills himself again with his
new pants
alright we got to go to class Prez it's
about time geography class good
it sounds so what this again no no no no
I had a thing about this no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no [ __ ] all right California
I know Florida [ __ ] me um try again what
I'm sorry that is incorrect
now where the [ __ ] is Alabama yes gasps
no whatever gave you that night no shut
up this is it
no I know tennis now that's all [ __ ] try
again
[ __ ] this one I know for sure I mean
this one yes yeah New York no you are uh
South Dakota is my again shut up try
again
shut up again all right I know for sure
it's this one - I'm having of course
Texas nail that [ __ ]
Utah there you are [ __ ] where are you
Utah your tie what the [ __ ] oh it's this
one I know for sure
[ __ ] Utah what the [ __ ] Kansas day why
don't they this is cancer this is cancer
dances Kansas
that's his cancer your mom's cancer
Michigan don't even Christopher Columbus
got lost on his way to India shut up
all right so the next one is with the
Nerds I guess they hate me now too as
well too as well I don't know what I
meant with that but rats in the library
can we do this one whatever neither what
are you guys talking about
J library is full of rats and I got a
pre pre pre med test next week oh that's
a lot of princess turned out to blue how
I longed for the old days sure we were
laughed at and mercilessly bullied by
everyone yeah least you could study
without fear of rodents coming near us I
don't see a single rat okay one right
get the [ __ ] up man yourself again algae
oh that's mastered I spilled soda on
myself sure what a bunch of sissies well
I'm not afraid of a few rats cheese
pathetic yay pathetic adios molto
pathetic Otto my yeah that's right
rat you don't [ __ ] with my am my rats
Miriam BAM this they're [ __ ]
everywhere [ __ ] shut up that's one nail
a nail dad yeah these are for [ __ ] yes
those crates the rats appeared once
those books were delivered everything
seems to be fine miss I think I got them
all Thank You Jimmy
you're welcome please I think we can
just forget about it's okay
long time ago I mean I mean press out
nail that with that was indeed nonsense
quite indeed splendid nonsense eyebrows
like a barrack a pound I'd subscribe
coma bro today and I will see you in
next episode probably the last 1000
Oh